plasma is the fourth state of matter  atoms and normal matter have a nucleus  with orbiting electrons in plasma the  atoms have been torn apart and the  electrons ripped away here on earth were  familiar with the three main states of  matter that were taught in school solids  liquids and gases you know we have the  atmosphere as a gas the oceans or water  the ground that I stand on is solid but  in fact most of the universe including  stars consists of plasma compared to the  rest of the universe  earth is a calm place most of the time  it's not hot or violent enough here to  create plasma the best place to witness  the power of plasma on earth is inside a  lightning strike  temperatures inside a bolt can reach  fifty three thousand degrees Fahrenheit  enough to momentarily rip a few atoms  apart the plasma lasts an instant then  the electrons rebind and it's gone  but in our massive Sun the plasma lasts  for billions of years and makes up the  entire 200,000 mile deep radiation zone